thank you very much it's a great
pleasure to be here
you see i put my title nice and high i
can't even
this is based on joint work with
sandra derocco
oh yeah
so first i should set the stage um
and for me the motivation comes from
some conflicting intuition
on one side we have the theory of torque
varieties
which i guess have appeared in many
talks although
often just in the guise of projective
space or products of projective spaces
in this workshop
and they are
very nice because they're computable
and combinatorial
i show up in many branches of
mathematics because of both of these
features
in applications it's the computability
that makes them particularly nice so
almost any question you can ask about
torque varieties you can actually
compute an answer for and understand
very explicitly
on the other side we have vector bundles
these are
much more complicated
and line bundles
so in algebraic geometry
or even differential geometry line
bundles are pretty
pretty easy to understand and we have a
good idea of them their positivity
properties being globally generated in f
ample etc
but when you try and extend those things
to vector bundles
the experience at least for algebraic
geometers is
almost everything that was nice here
fails for higher rank vector bundles
and so there's a lot of complications
that come in in passing from line
bundles to vector bundles
and so
right if we were in the torque settings
we'd be able to understand everything if
vector bundles in general
probably can't understand much what
happens when we intersect these two
all right so the motivation
is to understand the intersection and to
give
polyhedral
interpretations
or properties
of taurus equivalent
vector
and then see which of our two intuitions
win
so to do this let me be more explicit
and
talk about toric
vector bundles
so i need a base space so x
is a smooth
torque variety
i need a little bit of the combinatorial
data associated to this
so i'll let v1
v2
up to
vn can be the minimal lattice point
generating
the rays in the associated fan
we'll see examples in a moment um but
geometrically these
vectors
integer vectors correspond to the taurus
invariant
divisors in my torque varieties so
there's a nice geometric interpretation
combinatorially their lattice points on
the rays
the vector bundles i'm interested in so
script e
is a
taurus invariant
taurus equivalent
locally free
ox module
of
rank
r
which is finite
so
the taurus
because it's torque variety has an
algebraic tour sitting inside of it
the action of the taurus extends to an
action on the whole torque variety
that's essentially the definition of a
torque variety
and so that taurus equivalent here means
that that there's an action of the same
torus on my
vector bundle and it's compatible with
the map
down to the space uh hopefully pretty
finite rank so the thing that's nice
about this category is
cleachco
89
gave a alternative description an
equivalence of categories he told us how
to sort of describe in a nice linear
algebra way
these
toric vector bundles so e
corresponds
to
compatible
decreasing filtration
greg could you give us kind of like wish
list of what you're hoping to compute
so
so positivity conditions i would like to
understand for a torric vector bundle is
it globally generated or not is it very
ample
neph
um can i see
differential properties of it so all
sorts of properties of that flavor i'd
like to be able to understand in an
explicit way for torque vector bundles
chromology i'd like to be able to
compute in fact
klashko already tells us how to compute
that so that that's already known but
positivity conditions
right for on torque varieties for line
bundles it's pretty simple the smooth
hypothesis means that ample is the same
as very ample
globally generated is the same as being
neph so there's a lot of coincidences
that make
line bundles pretty easy to understand
on torque varieties and if i had my
torque intuition i would say well all
those things are going to extend i'm
going to see lots of nice coincidences
for torque vector bundles
but if i take my algebraic you know more
general algebraic geometry intuition i
will expect none of those coincidences
to lift
i'll expect everything to be different
so the question is
are there coincidences can i actually
tell
whether
a
torque vector bundle is ample globally
generated those sorts of things does
that answer your question
so we have a d compatible decreasing
filtration
i'll just work over the complex numbers
for simplicity so we just take the
vector space of rank the same as the
rank of our vector bundle or dimension
same as our vector bundle
and so decreasing filtration
pieces in the filtration i'll denote by
e
and it'll be indexed by one of our
vectors that's why i introduced them
so it starts with the whole space
decreases at some point down to zero
and we have one of these
where i is between one and n so for each
ray
and
j is any
engineer
so the nice thing about this is it turns
a very well algebraic or geometric
object
into a collection of vector spaces you
just need to know about these filtered
vector spaces and there's an equivalence
of category so
this is somehow
well representable in a computer a
finite amount of information concrete
and so we'd like to be able to work with
these
um
it's
i find this definition a little opaque
at the beginning so maybe an example is
needed to really get a feel for these
so let's not be overly ambitious and
work on p2
and then what are
my fan
p2 looks like this this is the
p2 so this lives in the plane
and
i'll choose v1 and v2
are the
standard basis vectors
there's one plane so this is
maybe d1
e2 pointing up
and my third ray
v3
in this case is minus v1
minus v2
3 or i guess the minimal lattice point
is actually the vector
and then i need a nice
taurus equivalent vector bundle to work
with
um and everything's nice in this
situation so the tangent bundle
on
p2
corresponds to some filtrations
now
right this way so three different
filtrations
i only have three distinct pieces
this is
how it works you get these now for j
less than zero it's the whole space c2
right tangent bundle of course
is two dimensional on something that's
two-dimensional
um and then i've identified or reviews
notation i'm using the same vectors
as a basis
for my c2 so i just take the span of
this
the
ith one so i get a one dimensional
subspace
which depends on which ray we're on and
then for j bigger than zero it's zero so
not a complicated filtration
um i find
expressions like this
again
not so clear i like to visualize it in
some way so what's compatible i see i
haven't i haven't defined compatible so
i'll get to that so i'm just
concentrating on the filtrations we'll
get to the compatible we're not we're
not there yet a filtration for each
each exactly for each eye i have a
filtration that's right this is i
between
one and three
so i have three filtrations and i
haven't yet said what compatible is i'll
work up to it in this example
but how to visualize these
really what you need to know
is the
place they jump
right you don't need to know
you know if for various values of j
they're equal for example for all values
of negative j that's not the interesting
information you need to know where it
changes
i mean wouldn't it be better it is i'm
sorry to be pedantic
but
cleopatra it's really e corresponds to n
compatible decreasing filtrations
right
what do we get three
that would you prefer
compatible drinking filtrations yeah
because you have any of them not just
one that's right i'm happy to make that
change
i'd like to visualize this um
in the plane
as a collection or a hyperplane
arrangement and if i think of in the
filtration corresponding to v1 it
changes at two points when j is zero and
one so i get
two places where it changes so when i'm
on zero or less over here i get a c2
here i get span
v1
and here i get zero so that sort of
encodes visually the filtration in one
direction
the filtration in the v2 direction going
up again
changes in two places
we have c2
we get the span
p2
so one dimensional thing and then zero
and then finally in the v3 direction
this was the origin
i get
again two guys
where it changes so i get a
c2 span
of e3
and 0.
so this feels a little better to me but
not great yet i think we can improve
upon
this so this is sort of a visual
representation of the three filtrations
that that go here
and what i'd like to do is actually
not keep track of all of this
information that's not necessary there's
some pieces of this picture that capture
everything and that's where this word
parliament comes in
parliament
polytopes
since x is smooth
there exists
a basis
of our vector space cr
for each maximal cone
our fan such that
each filtered piece
is a direct sum
of coordinate subspaces
for all v i in
sigma and all j
this is the compatibility
condition that frank acts about so i
have on each ray so in this case three
different filtrations and they have to
be aware of each other right they can't
just be completely arbitrary and so you
look at a maximal cone for example this
cone
and i can choose a basis
such that all the pieces that show up
here are coordinates direct sums of
coordinate subspaces and all the pieces
in the filtration in the other direction
are also coordinate subspaces and in
this example maybe i'll change colors
the basis
is v1
v3
here is v1
v2 and here is
v2
e 3. you always take the basis to come
from the
for the tangent bundle you can always
arrange to do that in general i mean
there's some coincidence for tangent
buttons
yeah i mean there could be i mean there
really are different bases as we move
around
and they can be
i mean
in this case
that's right the reason they come from
the rays of the cones is the tangent
bundle is a little special so that's
that's the
coincidence we're seeing here
so we have this we understand the
compatibility and then for each such
basis vector
in
c to the r we introduce
polytope
so p sub e
is a convex polytope so it's a set of
all vectors
in our d space such that
when we pair
against the rays for our normal fan
bit of a mouthful
so first of all we're
this is the half space right the the
normal vector is given by v i
and we're getting some half space so
this is an intersection of closed half
spaces so it has some chance to be a
polytope
now this max you know what the number we
do on the other side why does there even
exist such a thing well this is a
decreasing filtration for j sufficiently
large this becomes zero
and for j sufficiently small it's the
whole space so there certainly is a j
that contains every vector for small
enough j and there's also a largest j
which contains
this guy right i'm getting a little
overwhelmed here so we got a whole bunch
of integers we have r and r is the rank
of the vector bundle r is the rank of
the vector bundle d is the dimension of
the space
dimension of x
and n is the number of rays those are
the three
are these these coordinate subspaces
these come from the torus action at that
fixed point sort of mineralizing the
effector bubble there it has weights
that's right so i yes uh absolutely
there's several different ways to
interpret
some of that's encoded in this that's
right so let's
unpackage this definition in this
example to see what's going on before
you do this you say reach such basis are
these bases unique
these bases are not unique in general
for a generic vector bundle in some
sense they are unique but you can have
ones where there's some choice
so so there you have to to write down
these you have to make a choice of bases
you choose bases on each cone and you
write this down
you have to choose one basis on each
cone winfrind so it's not one basis for
cr it's one basis on each cone and you
can't get by with less than that in
general
if one basis works on all of the cone if
the same base is worked everywhere then
your vector bundle splits the direct sum
of line bundles
and then these polytopes are the
polytopes of those line bundles
so that's a very special case but in
general
you don't get that
question i i guess if the those basis
vectors are at the fixed points they're
not unique that's because the taurus
action has repeated eigenvalues that's
exactly what can happen
yeah
so in this situation in fact in this
example the tangent bundle on p2
we get
three polytopes
which
fit together
like this
three triangles
each have
lattice points at their vertices
those are the only lattice points they
contain
this one is
pv1
pv2
and p3
if we know these polytopes in fact they
were hiding
in this picture before
these are the ones that we extract out
from this definition
so we get
right if we were doing line bundles we
would have gotten one polytope because
well for a one-dimensional vector space
as soon as you choose a non-zero vector
you have a basis and there's no
complications going along so
you typically ignore the vector and just
write down the one polytope but if it's
a higher end guy you're going to have at
least
the rank many polytopes and if you have
exactly ranked many polytopes that's the
same as saying your vector bundle splits
the direct sum of line bundles so the
fact that we see three in this situation
is implicitly telling us that this did
not split as a direct sum of line
bundles
so that's nice
the e here is the v2
this is v1 and v3 so those are my three
different basis vectors going around and
so i only had three vectors in this case
and we end up with
three polytopes so the i
remind myself what the vector is by
labeling it on the bottom so that's
supposed to be a v2
if you're on pn
you've got a fully equivalent bank
effectively gln
g1000
and so there must be some correspondence
between sure
factories and
absolutely i haven't worked that out
carefully but absolutely there is of
course one yeah uh the
so suppose i like the cox ring i give
you a graded module
so i haven't produced a cox ring yet
for these things yeah so
they're
they're in fact the
the cox ring as you would normally
define it is the direct sum over all the
global sections over all the line
bundles uh for these spaces so maybe p e
for some torah character very bundle can
be defined it turns out it's not
finitely generated in general these are
not always murray dream spaces so it's
not
so nice to work with that in general
but it's an open question to
characterize which which vector bundles
is it omori dream space
i could write e as a module over the
coordinate ring of x sure
okay
um
not yet i'll i'll come back and suggest
how one can see that module
sorry i just
double questioned i just missed what the
parliament is oh parliament good
question parliament is a collective noun
so um we could have said the set of
polytopes or we could have said the
collection of polytopes but that was a
little boring um so
what i mean we could have been the
murder right a murder of crows
is the usual thing uh a parliament of
owls is the phrase that we stole this
from so there are many different
collective nouns so we just mean a
collection it's the collection of
polytopes we call the parliament i like
it because of the alliteration of course
um i looked in mass eye net it doesn't
seem to be used in a mathematical way
anywhere else in mass i net so we're not
going to run into any conflict
confusion that way it's also then nice
to talk about the member of the
parliament
um so that's
but it's basically a joke
yes
it leaves open many possibilities
so
okay we introduced this it's maybe a
visual way of representing and encoding
the
vector bundle but
who cares in some sense right
when we did it for line bundles in a
torque variety why did you want this
well in fact the loudest points in here
turned out to be nice for vector bundles
and in fact they turn out to be nice in
this setting
so we can understand the global sections
the lattice point
in the parliament
correspond
to the forest equivalent
generators
for the space and global sections
we get a nice way of describing the
global sections
just by
looking at these guys
this is almost the theorem we would have
said for line bundles except instead of
generators i would have said basis
and this example shows that there's
something a little different going on
you think of each lattice point
as giving me sort of the character data
and i have to remember the vector that
came with it
um
and so if we look at the origin lies in
all three polytopes so i get three
different
equivalent generators there but in some
sense they're lying in a two-dimensional
vector space and i can't have three
independent vectors in a two-dimensional
vector space so there's a relation among
them and it is of course this
relation that's coming into play so when
the polytopes overlap
you have to worry about the labels that
come with them
and this is a feature we see
that can contrast with line bundles line
bundles everything is purely
combinatorial here there's going to be
some linear algebra data that comes in
to play and the difference is for line
bundles there's no interesting linear
algebra in a one-dimensional vector
space there is at least some slightly
interesting linear algebra in a
two-dimensional vector space and that's
the difference
so can you say what the picture is
so if you if you take a line bundle then
r is one and so you just need to choose
one non-zero vector and that will work
all the way around
and so you can choose one vector and
there will only be one polytope to look
at and that is the polytope that you'll
find in
cox little shank or um
any other source that uh yeah i was told
by how it's oh shank in this context
yeah so it coincides or we're capturing
the standard picture uh for torque
varieties and line bundles um
did that answer your questions still
it's not just an interval in that case
it's still some positive that's right
depending on the positivity property of
the line bundle right
if it's a genuine polytope that has
points then they're global sections but
there are line bundles on projective
space that have no sections
in which case the polytope would be
empty so you see some positivity
properties of the line bundles in the
polytopes and we want to see the same
sort of positivity properties for vector
bundles
i'm confused greg
the euler sequence suggests that the
tangent bundle has eight vocal sections
that's right absolutely so so here i've
written down nine generators but the
three that
coincides with the origin are not
independent there's a relation so
there's eight independent ones exactly
but you said the lattice points in the
poly i see so you have to count the
origin
separately
so exactly the origin it lies in all
three polytopes so you you have to count
it with the polytope it doesn't count
once it counts for every polytope that
contains it
eight spaces
two to the three generators exactly it's
a way exactly weight space of dimension
two that has three generators exactly so
the cotangent space from this picture
you have to just start over
you uh you can write down what the yeah
you have to start over you write down
what the filtration is it's easy to
write down what that is and it turns out
the picture there are no sections there
so it's
yeah so the picture is not so
interesting in that setting but yes you
can work it out completely i i guess the
question was in general
once you have this done for the
inspector
do you get it for free for the duel you
have to start over again
you have to start over it doesn't come
for free twists is even more interesting
so twisting by line bundles we can also
do i'll come come back to that question
um
so this is nice we can see global
section but i'd like to know
is it globally generated or not right
this isn't
and i need one more piece of data so for
each
maximal cone
it turns out that an equivalent vector
bundle on an affine torque for id
always splits as a direct sum
so when i strict to sort of the natural
alfine cover
i get
some characters
use
our
so-called associated characters
all right so in
this example
maybe colors are needed we're going to
have
three maximal cones
and so which characters correspond
to this ones there are two characters
in play
so we get
we restrict here
these characters determine what happens
if we strict to the
fine open here these characters
determine what happens and these ones
determine that
we get this additional
data with that we can
actually determine if the line bundle is
globally
and the generated plane arrangement and
the polytubes all live in the same
space
so the
i think they live in slightly different
space the fan lives in d space
and the hyper plane range well no sorry
the hyper plane arrangement also lives
in d space so they they all live in the
same space yes
parts
parts lie in the d space why would they
be in the same space because that's
where the taurus is acting
the fan and the the fan of the polyp are
dual spaces
oh thank you so i've identified the dual
so i've identified the duals yes so the
same dimensional space but they should
be considered as dual spaces absolutely
the theorem
is that e
is globally generated
and only if
the associated characters
along two polytopes in the parliament
and
that's the combinatorial bit
the vectors
indexing these polytopes
span
c to the r
there's the combinatorial part and the
linear part showing up so for example
for this example if we look
all the characters belong to a polytope
and if we look at the blue guys this
corresponds to v2 and v1 and that was
the standard basis
if we look at the red guys we get
v3 and v1 that's also a basis
and
for the purple guys we get v2 and v3
that also forms a basis so we've seen
something that's well known that
the
tangent bundle on p2 is globally
generated
so that's what we
see in that situation so we get this
nice pictorial and in fact again it
degenerates the line bundle case to the
well-known situation for line bundles in
particular you don't need the linear
condition because you just have a one
vector in one dimensional space so
that's really the new feature showing up
sorry to get the decomposition along
each piece you need some other methods
or you see it directly from the
configuration
uh you have to do you don't see it
directly from the filtration you have to
do a little bit of work to compare them
but it's easily extracted from the
filtration
if it's not you have to compare the
appropriate pieces so to look for the
characters so you have to compare the
filtration for v1 and v2 to figure out
what the characters are
on that cone and go around but it's a
tiny bit of linear algebra not much
going on
so this is one positivity property which
we can see nicely in the parliament of
polytopes what about others
so what about say ampleness
so
there
is a matching
between associated characters
and adjacent cones
these are essentially the transition
functions and how you glue together as
you
put things
together and so for example if i'm
moving from the blue squares to the
purple circles you can see there's a
vector direction maybe i should use a
color
all right
tearing up those guys so going in this
direction
and if we work our way around these guys
pair up this way
and
these guys pair up this way
so this is the fact that it's a vector
bundle and they have to patch together
and you get these
things notice these
edges joining these guys
don't necessarily lie in one polytube
okay this one lies in two polytopes in
fact nobody said they have to be
contained in a single polytope or
anything of that sort the wine bundle
case of course they would be
but with that
we can reinterpret
work of herring
that a
contain
10
they say e is
ample
if and only if
the
distance
between
match characters
notice there's the directionality if i'm
going from the blue
to the purple i have to go in this
direction and so traveling in the same
direction means that this is a positive
distance right you could have had the
purple circle be on the other side and
that would have been
a negative
distance so it's positive
in fact these correspond to restrictions
of your vector bundle to the torus and
variant curves and so you're getting the
decomposition that way and so we see
from this since they're all
positive not only is the tangent bundle
globally generated it's in fact ample
again not a new result for p2 but a nice
way to visualize
these things
sorry positive there's a direction so i
mean i can their lattice point so i
could count the lattice distance if you
want and this is distance one
because i'm traveling in the same
direction i would if i was moving in the
fan
but if i had the purple circle on the
other side
i would be traveling in the opposite
direction so that would be lattice
distance minus one
so the fact that they always go in the
same direction as they would in the fan
does that answer your question david the
fans in one space and the poly token
joel's face so
so i'm looking at the normal to the ray
okay right and so that does correspond
to a direction here i am doing the dual
operation
that's a that's a linear space of
normals
so
they're talking about between faces so
it'll always be a normal direction which
is showing up that lines up here and
strictly the curves that answer your
question david
okay so this is a nice one and we can
see that we have
well pretty nice guy there
so with that we can
well we've achieved some of our goals we
can see positivity conditions
in the parliament of polytopes
and it also allows us to see
something new
in fact a question posed in the work of
elena sam and mircha
so we see some new phenomena
there exists
ample
but not
globally generated
or vector bundles
effect on p2 we can be explicit so for
line bundles this is not possible every
line bundle that's ample would in fact
be very ample
globally generated but for higher rank
things
these things can separate and i can sort
of
sketch a diagram
like the one we had before this time it
will be a
rank three
guys
what were my colors
squares so these are the characters
what
so the polytopes are
these four triangles
plus this one is the empty polytope so p
let's say e3 is maybe
no it's empty it has no points in it
so what's the rank of these
this is rank three
well you write down the inequalities and
there's no points contained in it
right but i thought you got these guys
correspond to some
well i mean it doesn't exist anywhere
but i'm starting the part the reason i'm
doing it is to be globally generated
the character would have to live in
something this character does not live
in a polytope so it's the problem the
polytope that would
hopefully contain it turns out to be the
empty polytope and so it's not contained
in anything so it's by the theorem not
globally generated so this is the
problem the local section it doesn't
extend or the whole stage exactly it's a
local section which does not become a
global section so there is no polytope
that contains this
the basis ones you construct there would
be one where you end up with an empty
polytope like the one you would have
hoped maybe would have contained this
one has no nothing inside it
all the other characters are contained
in genuine polytopes so this is the one
sort of witness of the problem
so if we first of all compare that's
what tells us it's not globally
generated and then we look at the edge
directions
and we see they're all positive and
that's what tells us it's ample so
a real problem here or some new
phenomena
can you see the restrictions to lines
the decomposition of restrictions
tonight
to the p ones you mean
yeah so in fact these
these are those restrictions so if you
restrict to the there's three
guys so if you want to restrict between
the blue and the purple that's telling
you one taurus invariant p1 sitting
inside
and your bundle when you're restricted
that be decomposes into direct sum of
three and the twists that show up are in
fact the lattice lengths that show up
here so that's exactly what that is
encoded in the data those are the
restrictions to the to the taurus
invariant lines can you see the
restriction to a generic one
not so easily no it plays nice with the
taurus guys and not so nicely with the
other guys
so we see some new phenomena we
some things worked well
some things didn't work so well
um but actually this i think is more
interesting
there are lots of questions in the
theory of vector bundles
which are
trivially true for line bundles and
torque varieties because all these
positivity conditions coincide for
example
there's a famous conjecture called
fujita's conjecture which tells you that
maybe on any vector bundle and any
variety smooth variety you can generate
ample things in a certain way those are
easy to see to be true on torque
varieties
but now
on the total space of the vector bundle
it's not so clear right this becomes a
serious testing ground for those
questions
which i think is nice
so it does
one thing that is a little strange is
the
restrictions the curves are these
distances between characters and they
don't
really have so much to do with the
polytopes right for line bundles the
restrictions would have been edges of
polytopes and edges of polytopes or
something we like combinatorially
these are no longer edges maybe the
question is do the edges have any
meaning
is there a geometric interpretation for
the edges
of the polytopes that were here and the
answer is
happily yes
jets briefly we say e separates
a jets
if for all
points little x and capital x
the natural map
from the global sections
of our vector bundle
to our vector bundle
just looking at what's happening
at that point
so this map
is really taking the taylor series or
expansion all the derivatives of our
section up to
k that's the map that's coming up here
that's why it's called jets it really is
that map and we want this to be
subjective
there's a condition we can ask
and it leads to a nice interpretation
the theorem
e separates
a jets
if and only if
the associated characters
are
contained
in polytopes
i should say let's say edges
of length
at least
okay
and we need the second condition as
before the vectors
indexing these polytopes
this gives an interpretation for the
edges right if we look at this character
it's saying
this part
is one jet spanned sort of locally here
but here because the polytope is empty
it's not so if we go back to our
tangent bundle
we can see that in fact
it is
separates one jets
it looks like this
so all the characters
lived in polytopes whose edge length was
at least one
so
the tangent bundle on p2
is
or separates
one jets
we do get an interpretation for the
edges in terms of jets that
have been known for line bundles
beforehand but nicely extends and we
really see the difference between
restricting to towards the very curves
is a different
sort of edge length or
between characters than the jets so we
see that separation which we didn't see
before
and
the corollary
which is particularly nice
is that e separates
one jets
if and only if
he is
so for
torque vector bundles we can see just
from the edge lengths of the polytopes
whether
it's very ample or not so we get this
nice condition going back i should say
that this
coincidence between two different
positivity conditions here is actually
false if we're not working with torque
vector buttons we just work with
arbitrary vector bundles on a smooth
projector variety that you can define
one jet and very ample and they don't
coincide
there's a difference between them
so there's something nice
about torque vector bundles we're seeing
sort of the torque side of the picture
come through that there are some
coincidences and some nice situations
arising
in fact we could tweak
this example
if i imagine moving this hyperplane down
so it just intersects this point
then i can get something which is ample
and globally generated but not very
ample because the polytope here will
just have a single point the edge
lengths won't be one so it won't be very
ample but
it will satisfy all the other properties
so
these things which coincide for line
bundles are all different for vector
bonds
i just wanted to make sure
you take all the characters from all the
affine pieces and all of them must
belong to long edges that's right
absolutely every character from all the
pieces has to belong to long edges so
exactly so here we
go we had to look at the two
corresponding
to the
circles these
we have to look at those two belong to
two long guys
we need to look at
these guys
triangles and
sprayers
okay check
all six in this case
see that folks
and
in this case
that wasn't globally generated so it has
no chance of being very ample
maybe this is a good place to stop
okay questions
so how much um
to what extent do these pictures
kind of describe the entire i mean if i
draw a picture can you tell me if it's
can i draw oh i need two things you
could you the i need a parliament of
polytope so some collection of polytopes
and the outer normals have to be
compatible with the fan so they have to
end and i need the compatibility
condition i need the characters to have
a matching okay that's the other
condition i need so the
the the
supporting hyper planes to your
polytopes tell you where your
filtrations break down but you need the
characters to ensure the compatibility
the matching condition so
it's in practice pretty easy to see that
in a picture but
absolutely there's
properties then then you've exactly then
you recover the clash code data and you
have a torque vector bundle so you can
deform these the way you were exactly so
you can deform them you can really do
visual things like i was suggesting and
reconstruct yeah absolutely and that's
in fact
right this example was constructed by
doing some sort of diagrammatic search
like that i should point out this is in
fact you can't do this with rank two
it's not possible for a rank two bundle
to be ample but not globally generated
but rank three you stand higher you can
do it so
the pitchers allow you to see things
like that
so this is a bundle of rank three on the
plane on p2 exactly yep minimal
resolution because this looks like the
toyota bundle and which has not
trigger splitting type and if it is the
same it's quite interesting because i
don't think it was known it was ample
so maybe we can
oh i don't know that bundle so we should
talk about that i don't know the answer
to that question
so can you show for example every
rank 2 torque vector bundle on p8 splits
as a direct sum of line buttons
so i there's work previous work um by
klashko who deals with some of these
things
and so for low rank torque vector
bundles i think if the rank is lower
than the dimension of the projector
space it has to be strictly lower than
they always split so in particular
things like the horix mumford bundle is
not a torque vector bundle okay we did
think we were getting everything
so but the for projector space that's
known and that's in some sense because
the fan is so simple
analogs of those results for other
torque varieties are
completely unknown
uh so
that is interesting
so
frank
schreier and sam payne and i
spent a few hours once trying to figure
out whether there were toric um
supernatural bundles on p1 cross p1
so that would mean
that you know you have certain vanishing
of chromology of twists
um
so it depends on what you think the
definition of supernatural should be i
think that
which was
these three
um
these three roots of the oil
characteristic colony
right so three
three twists which had zero homology at
all degrees
okay i think
yeah no i don't i don't know how to see
that immediately from the pitchers um
so
so one difference i noticed from david's
question so this on the left-hand board
the
this is the weight lattice of an
irreducible gl3 module s21 and but this
doesn't look like one
uh to me uh maybe i just missed it but i
don't know but i wonder if that's uh if
that's possibly one of the things that's
causing this new phenomenon that these
weights don't patch together to give an
irreducible representation of gl3 in
this case
i
i mean i agree with that statement i
don't know if that's a general
phenomenon i haven't looked at that
emergency so if i'm
a grad student and i care a lot about
productive spaces and products of
protective spaces and fairnesses but
maybe i'm not familiar with the theory
of line bundles and
vector bundles on all of these things is
there like a takeaway
for me
um vector bundles are more complicated
than line bundles i don't know if i have
something um but
for in both situations that when you
have a taurus action that gives you a
lot of structure and you can hope to
compute lots of things and that's merit
i mean maybe that's the takeaway with
enough structure and torah seems to be
enough in this case
i should say maybe to contrast it i'm
if i take p of e
right somehow the space lurking around
that i'm interested in that's not a
torque variety is the projectivized
vector bundle
and these pictures are telling us about
line bundles on this so the questions
about vector bundles can be recast as
line bundles on a different space
so that's one thing we're doing
um
and some these are examples of something
that's more generally known as a tea
variety but they're very specialty
varieties
right we really understand the global
sections of line bundles right the first
thing i said is the lattice points tell
us about the global sections so these
are pretty nice compared to general t
varieties so there's somehow a space
between torque varieties and
much more general things that seems to
be better behaved maybe that's the
takeaway so
can you compute for example the classes
from the parliament of the
uh
so the turn classes to
yes so klashko explains how to use the
he doesn't do it in terms of polytopes
but one can recast it that way and
describe churn classes of things
absolutely yeah
that's gonna work
okay if there are no more questions
we'll thank greg
you